Alright Michael, you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. What's the answer? Walk me through.
>> I will walk you through. Alright. So
let's, let's do this. Let's write the Euclidean distance.
Well let's write the Manhattan distance, because I don't,
I don't want to take square root to my head.
>> Okay.
>> Let's write the Manhattan distances next to the Xs.
>> OKay.
>> Or the Ys.
>> Alright.
>> Either way.
>> Let's do it next to the Xs. So this is
the Manhattan distance or MD as the cool kids call it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is that true?
>> Yea.
>> The cool kids called it L one.
>> No, no, no have you ever heard a cool kid ever say something like L one?
>> Well, to me the cool kids are the people
at neps who know more math than I do. Yea, do
you think any of them are going to watch this video?
Actually I'm afraid all of them are going to watch this video.
>> Now I'm really afraid.
>> Mm-Hm so you better get it right, every ones watching.
>> All right, well let me do, let me complete the Manhattan distances.
So the first one what you do is you take the 1 minus 4.
>> Mm-Hm.
>> And that's three. And you take the 6 minus 2 and that's 4. And you add the
two together and you get 7. Which interestingly is
the same as y, but I think that's a coincidence.
>> Okay. [CROSSTALK]
>> And now I'll do all the rest of them
'cause I pre-computed them of Four, six, eight, four, six. Alright,
so now we've got it set up so we can do
one and three nearest neighbor relatively quickly. So, the one nearest
neighbor, the closest distance, is four.
>> Mm--hm.
>> But unfortauntely there are two points
that have that two comma four in set
number one. We have outputs of eight and
50 because they. Almost agree with each other.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Not. And if we take the average of those two things we get 29.
>> Yep. That is correct Michael.
>> Great now in terms of the three nearest neighbors we have the fours and
the sixes.
>> So the four, three nearest neighbors.
>> Yep.
>> Somewhat awkwardly. And the we have the average of those things which is
what. Eight, fifty and sixteen and sixty
eight which gets us thirty five point five.
>> Right. Obviously. [LAUGH] Okay. Alright,
so that was pretty straightforward. And those
answers aren't too far off from one another. So what about the Euclidean case?
>> Alright,
so one thing to point out. I, I was worried
about computing square roots but it occurs to me that
I actually don't have to compute square roots because that's
the monotonic transformation, and we only care about the orders.
>> Hm, okay.
>> So for Euclidean distance, or as I like to call him casually, ED,
>> Mmhm.
>> We can just take the square differences summed up.
>> Okay, so this would be ED squared.
>> Yes, it would be ED squared.
>> Okay, ED.
>> Good.
So the first one, it'll be the one minus four is three, squared is nine. And the
6 minus 2 is 4, squared is 16. And 9 plus 16 is 25. So the first one will be 25.
>> And notice the square of 25 is pretty easy to compute.
>> Yeah, but the other ones aren't going to be. It just
so happens that we've got a pythagorean triple on our hands.
>> Mm. I love those.
>> Al right so the remaining ones, the x squared are eight,
26, 40, ten, and 20.
>> Hm, none of
those are easily square rootable.
>> Exactly, though 40 feels like it really was trying and failed.
>> Yeah. An eight over shot and now it's
a perfect cube. So, eight is the smallest distance.
>> Yep.
>> And again, seemingly, coincidentally, they
Y value associated with that, is eight.
>> Hm.
>> So an eight, eight is our answer.
>> Good and that's correct.
>> And the three closest are eight, ten and 20.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And if we
average the Y values for those that's eight, 50 and 68, which gives us
an average of 42. The meaning of life, the universe. And pretty much everything?
>> Yes! And that is absolutely correct. So that's kind of That's kind
of cool that you get completely different answers depending upon what you do.
>> Yeah, it does seem very different, doesn't it?
I mean there's like several orders of magnitude spread here.
>> Well, that's.
>> Maybe not orders of magnitude but orders of doubling.
>> Yes, there are orders of doubling spread. Well, you know what
Michael, I actually had a specific function in mind when I did this.
>> Okay! Let's find out which one is the right one!
>> Well, the function I had was Y was equal to the
first dimension squared plus the second dimension. So, let's call that X1
and X2, and this was actually the function that I had in
place. So, you square the first term and you add the second.
>> Okay, and
so like looking at the second last one, for example, seven
squared is 49 plus one is 50 Oh, [UNKNOWN]. It's very consistent.
>> Thank you. So what would be the actual answer for four comma two?
>> Okay so four squared is 16 plus two is 18. Which is close to none of them.
>> Right. So there's a lesson here, there's several lessons
here. And one lesson I don't want you to take away.
So here's the lesson. So I actually had a
real function here. There was no noise. It was fairly
well represented. The proper answer was 18 and basically none
of these are right. But the first thing I want
you to notice is you get completely different answers, depending
upon exactly whether you do one versus three, whether you
do Euclidean versus Manhattan. And that's because these things make
assumptions about your domain that might not be particularly relevant.
And this sort of suggests, that maybe this thing
doesn't do very well. Uh, kNN doesn't do very well because
none of these are close to 18. That seems
a little sad. But I've good new for you Michael.
>> Okay.
>> The good news is that, actually kNN tends to
work really, really well. Especially given it's simplicity, it just
doesn't in this particular case. And there's really a reason
for that, and it has to do with this sort of.
Fundamental assumptions in bias of kNN, I happen to pick an example that
sort of violates some of that bias. So I think it's worth to take a moment
to think about what the preference bias is for kNN and to see
if that can lead us to understanding why
we didn't get anything close to 18 here.
>> Okay that sounds useful.
>> Okay, so let's do that.